welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how
everyone's favorite web slinger might
rot
in prison lock him up
no no no no not my peter
not my peter the the news i watch tells
me
that it's confirmed that there's some
stuff on his laptop they don't
tell me what it is but now i've heard
that you can't trust
the media ever about peter parker when
it comes to spider-man
you can only get it straight from the
source i'm talking it's either joe rogan
yeah yeah joe rogan on may
uh and maybe you can trust flash
thompson
his instagram has all the big scoops
well i'm eric boss here with me today is
i just learned birthday boy tommy
bechtold happy birthday hey buddy
thank you thank you what a what a time
to be alive
as much as i'd love to not count this
entire year towards my tally
the calendar will not lie and i've
turned another year older so thank you
thank you you might feel like you are
five years older than you were last year
but you're
one year older and we're happy that
you've spent it with us
what a great year thanks ben because
you've been what an amazing year
what a great opportunity to meet new
people digitally
i truly genuinely do mean that despite
how sarcastic that sounded hey that's
the
only way it's happening right now yeah
that's true
well it's a it's an exciting time for a
lot of reasons but one big reason is the
third
mcu spider-man film has been filming in
new york in recent weeks uh and the big
question coming out of far from home
was wait a minute is peter parker going
to jail
what charges are they gonna try to stick
to the stickiest stick
boy the mcu yeah they gotta get him they
gotta get him he needs to go down so let
me let me ask eric this is my question
how much damage could spider-man be
legally responsible for
oh this is i love this question we do
talk about this all the time behind the
scenes
uh it actually comes to us recently from
our discord pal unpantalone
who asked specifically what would happen
if peter went to trial for
murdering mysterio and what's
interesting about this is
the public narrative what exactly does
the common folk think about peter parker
right now
because it seems like society believes
all the monsters that they saw in mexico
venice prague london were legit attacks
that mysterio was trying to stop
until that dumb ass spider-man murdered
him
saying execute them all
execute order 66.
it's not clear it's totally what the
public knows but it seems like people
think
that those drone strikes were operated
and controlled by peter parker
trying to steal it from his mentor tony
stark those are not great optics for him
gotta be honest do it execute them all
oh great odin's raven so
using that now we can try to think about
what the
world's district attorneys and
barristers lawyers
courtrooms around the world would try to
put on peter parker
starting with the charge of murder
so uh quentin back died on tower bridge
that is
if he died uh we're assuming he's dead
for this
uh episode and tower bridge is within
the jurisdiction of the united
kingdom which is interesting because
they have a completely different
legal code there even though common law
american common law is based on english
common law it's
they have similar legal traditions but
in cases of murder in the uk
youths under the age of 17 would be
tried in what's called crown court
but the sentencing guidelines tend to be
generally protective
of the perpetrators youth and immaturity
the same way they are in the united
states so there's usually they may not
be tried as an adult they kind of look
at obviously case by case uh the
severity of the crime
now there is an argument to be made
based on peter's birth records that he
should maybe be in his early 20s because
of the blip right good point
they tell us august 4th is the birthday
we haven't seen any proof of it but in
far from home that argument didn't stick
for
flash when he was trying to drink booze
on the plane so i i don't think it would
hold up in court
but i admire flash's ingenuity there
brilliant
smart man i'd be doing everything if i
was like 21 when the blip happened i'd
be trying to rent
a car yeah i'd be getting kicked off my
parents health insurance all that stuff
yeah i heard they recently decided to
add more hops to it
the problem is for peter however the uk
decides to try him his actions might not
be limited to murder
but would probably be linked to all the
terroristic attacks on tower bridge the
tower of london and then other parts of
europe prague
the venice grand canal and in such a
case i think peter could face a trial
for
war crimes in the international criminal
court at
the hague since its founding in 2002 the
icc has convicted and sentenced a
handful of war criminals
like the congolese warlord thomas
lubanga who was sentenced to 14 years in
prison
islamic militant ahmad al-faqiyah mahid
probably saying that wrong i was
sentenced by the icc to
nine years for destroying religious and
historic monuments in mali
which is interesting to point out
because a lot of peter's crimes are like
property damage he takes a lot of
monuments down for sure
yeah and we'll explore this deeper but i
do think it's likely that the u.s would
form an agreement with some of these
other
countries to indict peter under general
war crime charges
under the sokovia accords which various
marvel filmmakers have recently reminded
us are still
in effect in the mcu so let's move on
from murder to
the property damage we'll take off our
our barrister wigs and put on
our insurance adjuster cash all right
check we're all done with the murder
investigations now let's take a look at
all these
buildings that have been bombarded so
included and whatever indictment was put
on peter parker would almost certainly
be the various cases of property damage
and peter
even if he is able to get out from the
criminal uh charges
he could pay some civil suits so let's
try to put some uh a price tag on each
of these starting with uh spider-man
homecoming the staten island ferry
yes in half a lot of new yorkers count
on using that ferry to get to
and from work every day and for him to
separate in half make it inoperable so
many cars sunk into that hudson
covering bodies that still need to be
discovered from the mafia that bury them
there
never going to be found thanks to peter
parker i looked up those current fairies
there's a whole bunch of them there's
like a fleet of them
the numbers i was able to find for some
of the more recent boats is around 16
and a half million each to construct
them
down at a shipyard new orleans the ferry
itself brings in an estimated six
million dollars of annual revenue to the
city so
if one of its seven boats was destroyed
that's about
160 thousand dollars in lost revenue
for one boat plus each boat carries
about
30 cars and a lot of those cars sunk
into the river if you average about
twenty five thousand dollars per car
that could be about seven hundred fifty
thousand dollars
so not including the rescue salvage
cleanup we're just gonna round the cost
of that incident to 18 million dollars
not an insignificant amount of money
eric and let's just hope that everyone
had insurance
including spider-man all right let's
move on to the washington monument
i will say peter didn't do too much
damage other than you know there's a
broken window the elevator seemed pretty
toast
but as a 135 year old national monument
it's pricey to restore those things you
can't just bring in some contractor off
the street he's like yeah i can get some
chalk in there yeah
like you gotta get like uh precious
historians are like
careful the limestone is ancient right
in 2011 there was an earthquake
uh there's been a couple earthquakes but
after the 2011 one there was a
billionaire who paid
7.5 million dollars of his own money to
repair the monument
and another three million dollars to fix
the elevator so just using those numbers
for the damage that was probably done to
it spread around homecoming
we got 10 and a half million dollars
unless and
as always rich people will do anything
to avoid having to help poor people
we will just go ahead and divert 7.5 mil
to repairing the washington monument
meanwhile
never mind too political so it's a tax
write-off you know you get uh you get to
pay less taxes
he's just playing the system man he's
smart it makes you smart absolutely he's
gaming the system he's playing five feet
chess
all right moving on to spider-man far
from home tower bridge
in london so initial construction of the
bridge in 1887 cost
1.2 million pounds which is about
136 million pounds today and
in 2008 it got a little facelift that
cost
uh four million pounds so watching that
movie the drone destruction wasn't too
severe it looked like most of the damage
was to the vehicles on the bridge but
there was some heat damage some
explosion blasts
that took out you know certain uh
edifices
the structure there's definitely
structure damage and i would say
it's at least double of what that 2008
restoration did yeah
i would say plus all the vehicles
damaged on the bridge you know rounding
up and then converting it to us dollars
we got about
about 10 and a half million dollars of
damage to that one 3.5 million
hmm wonderful not total destruction but
no
sizable pretty devastating but that
wasn't the only landmark that was
attacked in that battle
the tower of london a unesco world
heritage site one of my favorite places
in the world
i've been to several times a few of the
drones damaged suits of
armor and medieval weaponry in the
armory of the tower of london that stuff
is
priceless it's like treasured items
a lot of it belonged to different
monarchs some of those suits of armor
and their cultural relics but i would
say they're not necessarily destroyed we
didn't see armor melting they're just
kind of knocked
on the ground and stuff but it would
cost a lot of money to restore them
based off of restoration costs and a lot
of those numbers are inflated but we're
going to give about 250
000 to restore all that that seems fair
now let's just hope that the
secret bar in the tower of london was
not harmed which
is a legend that every time i've asked a
guard at the tower of london to tell me
about they
not only deny they deny with such
frustration and anger because i'm sure
they're sick of it like because it's
like a tourist rumor that there's a bar
in there and i feel like
if there was at this point someone would
have been nice because i've asked 500
employees of the tower of london and
they're like it's not true
there's not one here leave us alone
please you know what you got to do is
ask the six ravens that are always on
because they know where it is quoth the
raven the bar is down there
all right let's move on to prague so
there was a city block of prague that
was pretty
messed up in that movie the ferris wheel
the fountain
construction costs for smaller ferris
wheels tend to clock in around three
million dollars
but there was a lot of fire impact
damage to the to that fountain there the
city streets buildings cars we're gonna
price it around nine million dollars
in damages the real price tag comes in
the venice grand canal
so here's the deal with venice flooding
in venice is a
huge existential problem to that city
there was uh recent flooding in november
2019 that caused a ton of architectural
damage
that the city mayor estimated to be
higher than 1.1
billion dollars with a b there's
constant reconstruction efforts to try
to keep
buildings floating as they uh race to
repair them
it's a huge problem now if you watch
that scene the hydra monster
caused insane levels of flooding around
the city buildings were crumbling
but really that flooding was quick it
was about 15 minutes or so
soon after the water subsided i still
think it's safe to say
a freak title shift like that you know a
lot of tsunamis are very quick as well
they just kind of their waves they pass
through and they destroy everything in
their wake
i would say 10 of the flooding damage
from last year so let's price it at
100 million which would be a safe
estimate to what
mysterious drones were doing absolutely
and if anyone
got any of that water on or around or
inside of them their medical bills will
be around 100 million as well because
that water
is disgusting and you know that's the
thing with all these numbers we're just
talking about uh structural damage we're
not talking about health care costs
costs as a result of trauma or injury
you know
all kinds of stuff that people could
have been hurt by speaking of trauma i'd
like to add the one time i went to
venice was
uh 15 years ago when i was even bigger
than i am now
and i was wearing my leather jacket and
little kids little italian kids were
taking pictures of me and yelling giant
following me around and yelling giant
gemini giant
giant and uh so i felt like a little bit
of a celebrity there but uh
it uh you should have scared them away i
said something a hydro monster is gonna
take this yeah i should have i should
have just started throwing them into the
canal
oh i'm sorry that happened to you tommy
but you're so well traveled
thank you thank you yes i've been
overseas before
we are international businessmen yeah
baby now the last town that was
destroyed and far from home was extenco
mexico that was the
the first uh city in the prologue um
it's a very small town
5 600 residents very old town founded in
1532.
the damage looks pretty severe uh and
like venice the city's old
you know any kind of restructuring is
gonna take a lot of time
and a lot of careful construction but
it's a much smaller city we're going to
use the ratio from what we paid for the
venice restoration costs
based on the comparative size of extinct
mexico priced at around
2 million in damage there so those are
the big ones luckily for peter his
webbing dissolves relatively quickly
we're not going to hold him for any of
his webbing damage across new york
there's a whole other conversation we
could have about what his webbing
dissolves
into is it a liquid is it a gas what
kind of environmental impact does that
have
this isn't ghostbusters these men do
have dicks we're not gonna have that
conversation
but that brings us at least for this
conversation to at least total property
damage that peter parker is responsible
for
150 million 250 000
oh that is a lot can it may help
no we may need to set up a gofundme for
him after this yeah
all right let's quickly run through a
couple other crimes that we might try to
stick to
first off trespassing obviously and
spider-man homecoming peter trespassed
into residence backyards and swimming
pools in the new york suburbs
he's always on roofs and scaffolds in
the new york area you're not allowed to
do that no i think it's illegal to go to
some of those places
absolutely peter trusts passed into a
dodc truck and then a storage facility
washington dc that's probably a federal
crime that he committed there
and then far from home he hitchhiked a
train from prague to berlin without
paying
and then uh he did the same from berlin
to the netherlands without paying fair
it's not necessarily trespassing right
what's the crime there it's
theft is stealing for if you don't pay
your fare there is a there's a term for
it right it's um
you know what john just edit me in with
your voice i'll move my lips
it's he needs some milk
but it's interesting whatever this crime
was is uh what got peter eventually
arrested in the netherlands
and he escaped from that prison which
would bring up prison escape as a crime
but but but
fun fact real fun fact while prison
escape is illegal in the u.s punishable
on top of whatever other crime you
committed to get in prison
prison escape itself is not illegal in
mexico sweden belgium austria germany
and
the netherlands so that's why peter was
allowed to get away with that if
you are caught yes you still have to go
back in those countries but they cannot
add
time to your sentence just for trying to
escape because their legal philosophy is
that
it is human nature to want to escape wow
imagine that yes now i know to commit
all my crimes in mexico sweden belgium
austria germany and
coming to your city soon netherlands all
right let's talk about truancy
so peter skips school a lot and in the
state of new york kids ages 6 through 16
must attend school full-time
if they skip they are liable to school
disciplinary action but in serious cases
they could end up in juvie
oh yeah but i would say considering
peter's academic status on the decathlon
team i doubt his truancy is that much of
a problem
he's pretty good about waiting out the
clock and then going off to be
spider-man
exactly but the one peter has to worry
about is the thing that
i believe got oj eventually arrested
unlawful detainment so peter webs up
people that he doesn't necessarily have
to
which could lead to charges like assault
kidnapping unlawful attainment now
new york law does allow for what's
called a citizen's arrest
in which a private person can use
physical but not deadly
just physical force to arrest someone if
they reasonably believe the person has
committed an offense
but in addition to that that person has
to have
actually committed the offense so when
he wept up aaron davis hand to the back
of the car
aaron davis was wanted for specific
charges that would have been an okay
citizen's arrest
but that one dude just trying to get
into his own car what peter did
was illegal it's my car dumbass hey
shut that up i was and
not only that at the end of the day he
probably would have gotten sued by both
people because he could sue anyone in
this country it's an infringement on
your constitutional rights
it's outrageous egregious for
possibilities
okay so moving on to our conviction in
sentencing i've heard enough
bang bang bang enough this brings us
back to the sokovia accords which are
again still in effect
these are specific to the mcu and i
think peter could be convicted for
unauthorized use of superheroic actions
at the very least
like from the moment he returned from
berlin in spider-man homecoming
everything peter does in washington dc
with the staten island ferry when he
engaged vulture on stark's jet that
crashed on coney island beach
these are all violations of the accords
which are you know
disputed but like still punishable
they're the law of the land right now
you love all the lands
peter joined tony stark and bruce banner
dr strange as it confronted the black
order in the park and infinity war a lot
of trees got damaged there
tommy and as we know from groot those
trees could be alive those trees can
think and they have souls they could be
sassy teenagers for all we know
and yeah coming back to his heroics in
venice prague london
even if they are heroics in public's
mind they all occur outside the purview
of any government authority nick fury
wasn't working
for thunderbolt ross there so even if
peter is exonerated of killing quentin
beck
he has still inserted himself in
avengers level threats without
authorization so
peter parker could very well be detained
in
the raft prison as we saw half the
avengers
in civil war and clint barton sam wilson
scott lang they were detained despite
not being physiologically enhanced they
needed their gear to be superheroes
peter parker even without a suit is
still a threat that's right
he has his peter tingles so we will see
i believe in the opening act of
spider-man 3
we're going to see these legal troubles
haunting peter parker and yeah our man
could go to jail oh i hope not
he's such a sweet boy he's a menace no
no no no
just give him a chance just give him a
chance
nah get to know him all right i gotta
walk up this steam i'll be right back
tommy
okay just settle down eric but take all
the time you need goodbye eric take care
goodbye now that he's gone let's
talk business i've been saying for years
the thing that this channel needs is a
little bit of a tommy takeover and it
seems as though
the powers that be have left the
driver's seat open
and i'm sliding in so starting very soon
i am going to have a dedicated time
where i can take over and run this
channel how i see fit
now i'm not capable of deciding things
on my own i'm very much a follower when
i was in high school i dressed exactly
like my friends and some days they just
wore burlap
sacks okay i was a sack boy in high
school so what i need from you
is suggestions of how to shape this show
what do you want to see from me what do
you want you want me to break down which
ghostbuster was the horniest i'll do it
you want me to break down uh
greatest water slides in america i'll do
that you need to communicate with me
whether it's on discord or tweet at me
or
find me on instagram we can talk about
this and let's shape this takeover
together
and if things go right by next year new
rock stars will simply just be called
the tommy b
experience yeah baby what what were you
saying to them nothing
nothing eric i'm so glad you blew off
your steam absolutely nothing happened
while you were gone
all right cause i didn't even take the
time to flush that floater
oh boy i just heard your voice and i
said i gotta intervene
i can smell it through the screen hmm
it's just a bucket that's all philip
gave me in the dungeon
fill up oh well phillips gonna have to
clean this spill out i was gonna say
that bucket's living up to his namesake
it's a fill-up situation it's a [ __ ]
bucket
in florida we call it a bumping bucket
yeah but that's because you bring it to
jimmy buffett concerts you take a squad
yeah hell yeah
because you don't want to miss
cheeseburgers oh god if you missed one
of his two famous songs
what was the point
[Laughter]
as long as he plays get drunk and screw
oh boy
all right uh moving on to some people
who helped us make this episode
starting with our friends at expressvpn
tommy have you seen the social dilemma
documentary on netflix i did the feel
good hit of the year i went out and
bought both of my daughters
cell phones and encouraged them to get
on facebook immediately
ah you took the wrong message away from
this it just all seems so glamorous to
me
oh man i would love to have uh pete
campbell from
mad men four of them inside my body
deciding what i get to see
yeah oh yeah is that what it is they
were inside the body they were inside
the app
i didn't understand but it did scare the
hell out of me
it is so good it explains how social
media is engineered to exploit users
data for profit
they call it surveillance capitalism i
do not want my data being harvested so
that tech billionaires can get even
richer
that's why i put a layer of protection
around my data with
expressvpn so every time you use the
internet big tech companies mine your
data by tracking your searches your
messages
your video history but when you run
expressvpn on your device it hides your
ip address
which websites can use to personally
identify you that makes your activity
even more difficult to trace or
to try to sell to advertisers so you
still need to be careful with what you
share on social media
obviously obviously tommy yeah i don't
share a lot uh just
daily workout updates and uh my internet
passwords
okay well you know you can just take
those sticky notes off your uh laptop
you shouldn't be having all your
passwords on a sticky note by your
computer
that's a good point but here's the deal
folks expressvpn can make your web
browsing more anonymous
expressvpn also encrypts 100 of your
internet data to keep you safe from
hackers and all kinds of pry and eyes
many vpns slow down your internet but
not expressvpn it's incredibly fast and
easy to use
just tap one button and you are
protected so if you don't like the idea
of tech companies exploiting your
personal information then visit
expressvpn.comq
right now and there you can get three
extra months of expressvpn
for free that is e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
big q to protect your data go to
expresscpn.comq to learn more
we also want to thank our friends at
acorn tv
it is time to burst your domestic tv
bubble and check out acorn tv a
commercial free streaming service that
is rooted in
british television it's home to
top-rated mysteries addicting dramas
heart belt comedies and so much more
acorn tvs content from ireland canada
australia
new zealand and beyond
i was gonna do all those accents in a
row for you do the exit for beyond
beyond look what i'm told oh god oh god
we went into love craft country
really what i've enjoyed about acorn tv
is discovering a show i've never heard
of with actors that i love like
the directorists with arnhem zola
himself
toby jones and mackenzie crook from the
british office
yes and game of thrones he warged into a
hawk and never came back
right acorn tv has lots of comedies and
more murder mysteries than you can count
if you need to escape for a few hours
with a charming detective with a great
accent and a teacup acorn tv is your
happy place plus
you can also play the how many game of
thrones actors can you spot this episode
game
which is really fun they've also got the
kind of charming low stakes reality
shows that i love sometimes i just want
to watch someone restore an 800 year old
castle
please you can stream thousands of hours
of great content
on all your favorite devices for just
5.99 a month
escape to britain and beyond without
leaving your seat try acorn tv free for
30 days by going to acorn dot tv and use
my promo code big question
that's a c o r n dot t v
code big question to get your first 30
days for free
okay and now comes the time for a bite
size question that our man tommy's gonna
answer for us
are you ready tommy yes cappy kid on
discord hey man
asks how does hyperspace in the star
wars universe work
interesting light speed hyperspace
as we know is a very complex thing in
star wars canon hyperspacing like dustin
crops boy
entering hyperspace means to move faster
than the speed
of light it's made possible by a
hyperdrive motivator
fueled with hyper matter particles which
are essential to the task and it might
be based on dark matter for uh
smartypants out there the ship's inner
computer automatically computes
and charts out routes that ping the
vessel across the galaxy at
light speed until it reaches its
destination in real space and i'm
talking
the real space none of this fake ass
space okay
therefore a ship speed is a function of
its computing technology
the millennium falcon heard of it can
outrun lots of other ships
because it has superior navigation
computer that can chart out courses
faster
and more efficiently than other ships
can it's also makes lando very horny
deep cut for those of you who didn't see
solo so there's your answer double k
these quantum computers
they have it's kind of like in dune
right the only reason they can do
interstellar travel
is because they have these like spice
coked up things
that can quickly quantify the
calculations
in star wars they have their their
navigation computers do that right and i
wouldn't be shocked if the computers
were on coke
they're just so fast and so up tempo and
they're always trying to get me to start
a business with them
any problem is solvable because we live
in the matrix
all right tommy great job and we move on
to our box scraps
one more question here here's the box of
scraps
it's personal one and feel free i i
guess to be as personal
or vague as you want tommy i think we've
answered something like this on the show
before but
sticking with the theme of what
spider-man's gonna go to jail for what
is the worst legal trouble that you have
ever been in
that you're willing to talk about sure
trying to think of one that i haven't
talked about on the show
before i you know i've got to say uh
despite
my bad boy outside i'm a pretty
uh rule abiding uh law-abiding citizen i
have been accused of of stealing before
and had the police show up at my parents
house i could tell that one i i was torn
between two
the one i won't tell is when i tried to
use vampire rules to argue why i should
be allowed to stay in a college
overnight when i got caught drinking
there even because i didn't go to the
school they tried to kick me out
but i said that since i had been invited
into the school i legally had rights to
stay there
i think yeah that's buffalo law yeah and
it absolutely worked on a like 21 year
old r.a
did not work on the campus police though
she was like it makes sense
i just got to tell the police officer he
said no
uh the most trouble i have individually
been in
was my cousin brian and i went to
a gas station to buy beer uh when we
were both underage and
i didn't i had a fake id but it was
really bad he had a really good fake id
so he went in to buy beer but there was
this guy
there who just was watching it wasn't
working at the store
he must have recognized him or something
or knew him maybe he was some with
someone one of our friend's dad but we
just didn't know
he was watching him so my cousin got
uncomfortable
and left then we drove away he's like
that was no good we drove away and went
somewhere else and brought beard another
place
so like an hour later my mom calls and
says that
they they took my license plate down as
i was leaving the parking lot
and they called the police and they
accused me of my cousin of stealing beer
so we now had beer in our car that we
had bought illegally
from another place and we were like and
we both had fake ids on us
but we hadn't technically committed the
crime they were accusing us of
committing
everyone okay i like the uh completely
composed badass that i am immediately
threw my fake
id theatrically out the window never to
be seen again i just whipped it into the
wind
uh and then we took our beers and we hid
them behind
one of the neighbor's houses
and then we went to my house and spoke
to the police officer we talked to the
cop and we're like no check the cameras
we didn't steal anything from that store
and the cop kind of was like
yeah the guy said he's absolutely sure
that you put like talking to my cousin
you put some beer under your coat and
left it's very cold as it always is
in upstate new york so eventually it was
like
dropped so that they could look at they
were like we'll look at the security
tapes and if we find something you guys
are in way worse trouble
for making us take these extra steps
well of course they looked at the
footage and we hadn't
stolen anything so we got off of it but
as you can imagine
i think we were 18 or 17 at the time we
still got in lots of trouble with our
parents
like there's like you can't you can't
walk away from that one without a little
bit of a stain on you
so uh i would say like legal trouble
that was pretty tame but that was
definitely my most intimate encounter
with the police
and unless we're talking about financial
and then we can talk about all the
speeding tickets that i've had
and how so much time in court i've had
to spend for that but in terms of like
an actual crime that was that's about as
bad as it gets for me how about you man
yeah i'm i'm in the same boat when it
comes to like uh speeding tickets movie
violations stuff like that i think i
have an unpaid campus parking ticket
which i just think is like
you know it's like monopoly parking
tickets there's not a real place
campuses yeah you've already uh stolen
enough of my money that's right tuition
what did i get from my money
i i think i i got one of those right
before i
graduated uh and i'm like oh god but it
hadn't been entered in the system so it
didn't affect me from getting my diploma
i still haven't paid it but i'll never
pay it i'll never go back there and then
when i moved out to la i did not update
my
license and registration in california
soon enough and i got pulled over
and like they impacted my car and i had
to go up here in court it was a whole
nightmare same-sex just do it that's my
advice too
don't just learn from us but i think the
scariest thing that still gives me
anxiety even though i don't think it was
legal trouble
when i was like eight uh my sister had
this system
uh for how to sneak into a movie at a
movie theater
uh and now i'm like working kind of in
this industry and ironically it was
for a pixar movie it was a bug's life
and i wanted to see it so bad and and uh
now my lovely girlfriend works for pixar
you owe them nine dollars that like pete
doctor's gonna know
and he's gonna be like you know we
looked up some jacksonville film records
and
we we had footage of you walking into a
bug's life at two thirty eight year old
to me who's
yeah just like the bart simpson arrest
tape like
but the way it worked uh we it didn't
work at all like i honestly went to the
movies that day thinking
that i was just gonna go in and see a
movie and pay for whatever the six bucks
was
to go see the movie there my sister's
like no no just do what i say
and she's like she goes up to the usher
we need to go talk to customer relations
and she's like okay go
and we waited for the usher to be
distracted and then we like snuck past
her
i s like we went in and you know we said
i'm like why didn't we paint she's like
shut up shut up shut up
we sit there and we're watching that
wonderful pixar opening short of jerry's
game or gary's game or the guy's playing
chess with himself and
i'm just like enjoying it and i look
over and that usher is in the aisle
staring directly at
my sister's like don't don't look at her
just keep looking forward
and i was like i got so scared and then
eventually another usher comes and he's
like hey can we see your ticket stubs
and my sister without missing a beat
goes we threw them away
yes and i was like and he's like can you
come with me please and the manager was
just like
you know she says that you didn't yeah
she remembers you
and then the usher looked and pointed at
me and she's like i remember him
i remember his blonde hair and i had
bright blonde hair
and i was like if i had only worn my hat
that would have avoided everything and
the whole drive home my sister was just
mad she goes like
she's like well i'm sorry and i'm like
i'm sorry
it's mine we're going to juice
oh my god how funny i i've only snuck
into one
movie in my entire life and it was the
uh kelsey grammer
classic down periscope
that's one that's like fair to sneak
into because it's down periscope
pixar makes these beautiful films that
we should all be paying for
especially now yeah you know i have a
reason to uh toots credit though
when we went to uh i i was able to see
onward
early and then i went back to the movie
theater and it was the last movie i saw
before everything shut down so pixar has
my money
and then i have more and more of my
money i will see every movie in the
theater twice
that i can because i love your face
you're you're i think you've more than
made up your karmic debt
to pete doctor not according to my
nightmares all right
fair enough i absolve you i'll i'll say
i'll light a prayer candle for you
tonight eric
uh hopefully neither of us will go to
jail for confessing these crimes
on a public youtube video ladies and
gentlemen
we got him
that is it for this episode of big
question tommy it's been great talking
about um
always a pleasure with you today and and
i'm just glad that while you went up and
walked away and blew off some steam
absolutely nothing happened here and
there's nothing that anyone should worry
about well i never watch these videos
back so i'm just going to take you for
your word great
that's smart well follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars
and check out our new merch store we
have lots of amazing
options including an exclusive this is
the way shirt oh hi i'm eric voss shirt
all kinds of great new rock stars merch
and other designs that you're going to
want to check out they got everything
that you might love in there
it's like our own personal hot topic but
better and it will help support this
channel you know that's that's just
something we're trying to get it looks
amazing
i have to say as a cynical internet
browser
i perused the entire store the other day
and they've got some sizes
they've got some babydoll tees that i'm
going to be cramming myself into these
holiday seasons
[Laughter]
and uh for future episodes a big
question send us your big questions
using the hashtag
bigquestion but really you're gonna want
to become a patron and so you can get
into our discord that's where we check
first for our big question submissions
as we did this episode subscribe to the
big question podcast feed wherever you
get your podcast leave us a nice rating
review if you don't mind
uh subscribe to new rockstars of course
here on youtube hit that notification
bell and uh we'll see you next time
bye oh [ __ ] the cops are here okay i'll
talk to him
i'll talk to him it's that one usher
from amc in 1998.
i don't have a fake id there is no tom
idaho
she's got your id too now that he's gone
i'm just kidding just choking
just joking what is this
[Music]
so
you